[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to bonehead of the week
this
this week's edition every friday in the
second hour of the tony michaels podcast
you know we air
every single weekday monday through
friday but on friday we do this special
segment bonehead of the week where you
guys go over
to at tonymichaelspod on twitter
take your vote for bonehead of the week
and then me and gabe break it down here
right here on the second hour of the
tony michaels podcast in the segment
called bonehead of the week and gabe we
have some really
i mean these are normal boneheads i mean
i don't i don't even know how many times
like well we really need to have like a
record thing going like how many times
these people will be you know i'm going
to i hear it next yeah
it'll just be like mtg it'll be right
lauren beaubert i have to go we have to
go back through the footage right to
figure out how many times because here's
here's our here's our nominees for the
week we have
representative if you loosely uh defined
marjorie taylor green uh senator rand
paul not his neighbor ran actually
actually ran ball yeah and then lauren
of bobo uh bobert
for the bonehead of the week that you
guys made your vote for
you guys made your vote for this week
and guess who won
[Laughter]
you know again i want to go back to
all three of these are like easily
easily the bonehead of the week right
i mean it's not difficult to see
why or how these three would become
bonehead of the week right
when you have these three on there but
it really was no competition yes like at
all
right marjorie taylor green headed out
front and stayed out front the entire
time at like 70 percent yeah
right is that is that the is that that's
just like whenever
no it's like a
it's like i i don't know it's you know
it's not quite a car it's not quite an
engine you know i don't know it's just
like
you know it's just like her taking off
ahead of the rest of the group you know
well we we have some uh special um and
dishonorable mention and alpha cook
which the dishonorable mention will not
surprise you either um the alpha cuck
it's not surprising but she i don't
think we really know who this person is
but let's start
with the the ultimate loser
bonehead bobert here uh lauren boober
why did we have her
on the bone head of the weak pole
she had a moment
this week where she was talking to
um
let me let me look it up really quick
she was talking to someone during a it
was a there's like a little hearing that
was being done where she was asking
questions with some other colleagues
there was only like five people that
were there yeah and one person answering
i didn't know if i didn't know if it was
the uh mickey mouse thing or not
no well i mean look
we could we could throw that in there
let me let me show let me show the
audience here um
because i believe i still have yeah i
just wait
let's see um
see if i can find it here but i was at
the mickey mouse thing because she
tweeted uh mickey mouse
and a lot of people called her out on it
right so the reason i brought her up was
because lauren beaubert kept asking the
u.s health chief if men could get
pregnant
so she took a page out of
now what
she wanted to know if men could get
pregnant
and you mean like a person without a
uterus is it what she's saying yeah yeah
yeah she wants them to define to be like
who are these people these you know the
man versus woman who can get pregnant i
wanted to be like let's roll the clip of
the arnold schwarzenegger movie
uh where he does give birth right
uh top-notch film should have gotten an
oscar for sure
um but
uh he
was like uh
what like i did like what why are you
asking this question and she was like
trying she was trying to have a gotcha
moment and it didn't really work out it
was like marsha blackburn came and it
was like what is a woman right well then
you see someone asked josh holly this
this what is a woman oh right yeah they
had followers a woman is barefoot in the
kitchen and can get pregnant and if she
can't get pregnant and she's no longer a
i mean he was like questioning like he's
like oh my god if if if a if a human
being can't get pregnant is it a woman
like he he really did not he did not
they have a hard time uh
they don't know what a woman thinking
well they have a hard time thinking
right well
let's play the clip of the mickey mouse
debacle though i actually i featured
that tweet but another quote tweet of it
on the show a couple days ago let's see
what else do we get going here
oh yes oh yes this is a great one eric
swalwall says m-i-c-k-e-y
because lauren bobert and bone-headed
[ __ ] she says next year the woke disney
lobbyist will ask congress to extend
mickey mouse's trademark i think not of
course she spelled mickey m-i-c-k-y eric
swallow points that there's literally a
song that taught millions of us how to
spell it if these losers aren't weren't
dumb we'd be screwed
m-i-c-k-e-y-m-o-u-s-e
you remember the song it taught us how
to spell it whoosh is it surprising that
lauren bobert doesn't know how to spell
mickey mouse i mean is it really
somebody sounds surprising
it really isn't what's surprising is is
that when she typed in mickey mouse on
her phone and i'm not sure i haven't
checked this but i would imagine if you
type in mickey mouse on your phone and
spell checks it so even her [ __ ]
phone is stupid
i actually checked this game i went and
made sure that i fact checked myself you
tried to misspell it yes absolutely and
the phone said there's a [ __ ] song
that's that's literally
i i asked siri i asked alexa and that's
literally what they said they're like
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me there's a
goddamn siri just
siri responds and goes
face palm you're right right right it
really is [ __ ] dumb cause like when
you start to spell up mickey mouse on
your phone right it smells it it spells
it for you so even her phone is [ __ ]
dumb even her phone is a [ __ ]
bonehead all right let's move on to rand
paul i don't know if anyone knows
why we put rand paul on uh other than
he's just a complete dumb [ __ ] i mean
yes that's an easy one um but yesterday
uh and several people on this show
watched yesterday at the very end of the
show
uh that scumbag mitch mcconnell um came
out on the senate floor and gave his
statements about the
um the confirmation vote of katangi
brown jackson now justice brown jackson
um he gave his deplorable statements and
when he when he started the lie game
when he when he went into let me go
through
what i don't believe a
goddamn word from that guy's mouth he's
still trying to flush those documents
down his toilets that he said still
getting pissed about right right so so
mitch mcconnell i muted him and then we
had chuck schumer and we watched the
vote but when there was one vote missing
and i didn't know who it was at the time
when we were on the show i was like who
the [ __ ] is missing there's one vote
missing
right but you shouldn't have had to
guess like you didn't have to guess it
really i mean it was kind of i think you
had a tweet yesterday which is like
we're waiting for right right this is
right you know like
literally literally we've been waiting
for him to pluck his head out of his ass
for years and years and years and we're
going to wait a bit longer and probably
now longer still
i mean it's not like they even needed
the vote anyway
but
you know it's
to
to hold out like you're like all right
they've got 53 you know let's call it
5346 because this dumbass doesn't like
he wants to it's like that pose that
trump had with like you've got like the
g
like the whole like global uh leaders
you know and he's like
you know just like this that's rand paul
in many ways other than the only time he
ever gets engaged with something is when
he's like trying to take in
uh russian money right well yeah why i
mean he is he is he is a pro putin pedo
con um but he i said we have we have
been waiting on rand paul to pluck his
head out of his ass for a long time
probably gonna wait a bit longer here is
the actual screenshot of what c-span had
up they actually posted even
even c-span burns rainbow like waiting
on this [ __ ] like we're waiting
this this week
yeah it's like he i guess has to he has
to give some indication
of like
uh not participating or participating in
uh yes no
but the fact that he just like you look
at it and you're like okay like we
already knew leading up all 50 democrats
were going to do it and we have three
republicans who are going to vote yes
so you already know the outcome there's
no way unless you're going to uh just
all of a sudden
persuade someone
to change their vote like it's gonna be
she's gonna be confirmed because you
guys put this rule in place when you
guys wanted to force through ac like amy
coney barrett so don't get mad when you
didn't you know you weren't able to
filibuster all this [ __ ] so i'm
sorry you guys set the rules and the
precedent we just use them but we don't
actually need your vote so the fact that
you're holding out
is so petty and childish
it makes you look like an even bigger
ass
right like you just could have been like
i vote no and that's it i said my piece
but the fact that you had to hold off
your vote and wait
yeah well you know maybe maybe he was
taking a [ __ ] maybe he was immersing the
wounds that he still has from his
neighbor
i don't know i don't know i mean they're
still probably he i mean you know that
neighbor we should give him a medal of
honor but here i i will tell you that um
rand paul even though it was boneheaded
for him to try to hold the vote whatever
he was trying to do whatever his
motivations were i think it was just he
wanted to get the attention right
the one person that we did not give
attention to because of it was that
uncle tim scott that [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] oh god who who not only voted no on
the first black woman to become a
supreme court justice but he walked up
and did a thumbs down like he made a
show
out of voting against the first black
woman which kind of [ __ ] gross
especially when he knows she's qualified
and i believe he even put a statement
out saying that oh yeah she's qualified
and blah blah blah but it's a no vote
for me because
i'm i'm a pro putin petticon like that's
maybe the the thing that they're the ppp
right ppp hey that's pretty good maybe
they want that money get some of the ppp
money yeah well that could be that could
be uh you send me a link here let's go
back for just a second because you sent
me a link here of the uh
of the boba yeah in case any in case
anyone doubted me i said there's like
five people that are talking and there's
one person responding and it's the
health chief right and then well yeah
is the uh
he's he's a former congressman right
yeah
and
but let's let's let's watch to start off
as a secretary of health and human
services can you define for this
committee what is a man
you're looking at one
great
so you are a man i like that
can you tell me
can she she did not expect him to say
that yeah she was like oh okay she
expected him to say like because she
expected the she wanted the definition
right right yeah right again she saw
marsha blackburn do this and then she
goes i'll take my beer you're right i'll
do one even i'll do one even more stupid
so she's like she's like she watches
marsha blackburn make a total fool out
of her [ __ ] self
and and she's like you know what that
was such great that was such a great
clip that i really want to look like a
dumb [ __ ] yeah ben get pregnant
what what what what was that like you're
asking if men can get pregnant
so you are a man i like that
can you tell me
can men get pregnant
unless you know something i don't i
think the answer's pretty often
can't we gotta stop there we got his
other because he's like he's like
we're in it we're in it because i don't
know what this committee hearing is
actually about like the actual subject
but he's like i'm here to actually
answer questions for the record for the
american people as the health and human
service secretary like this this more
than likely is a is hearing about health
care right like important matter in to
american people most american people
don't want to go broke or bankrupt
because of a medical bill and this is
the person uh one of the people that is
in the administration that is standing
between uh that organization or that
that institution the health and human
services and making sure that americans
don't just go broke because of medical
bills and here he's like having to
answer questions if men can have babies
he's like are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me yeah
sir sir
i'm asking you is there something you
know that i don't know that would say
that a man well i'm asking what you know
can men get
pregnant i'm not aware of it okay well
um mr secretary materials coming from
your department you've referred to
mothers as as birthing persons replacing
that title with
are our mothers not persons
so this is this is what i've said
several times is when someone asks you
out there if you're listening and
someone asked you like they're like
they're trying to get you because you're
libtard i'm gonna get you i'm gonna wrap
you up in this argument about a man and
a woman so when some dumb [ __ ] ask you
what's a woman do you know what a woman
is you say
yes it's a gender that a person
identifies as right it's really simple
it's it's not complicated it's a gender
that a person identifies as and then if
you really want to get them if you
really want to catch them you say what
gender do you identify as right and
they'll say well i identify as a man oh
okay so you understand what a man is
then it's a gender that someone
identifies as and they'll get in their
cells in the lubricant right right
no all right right exactly
right that's exactly how you do it so
just maybe we'll work you know play this
over on the loop if someone asks you
what a woman is you say it's a or a man
either way it's a gender that a person
identifies as and then you just follow
it immediately you say what gender do
you identify as and they'll say their
gender and you say okay so you
understand what what a man is or a woman
whatever the case is that's how you do
it and they'll [ __ ]
hopefully they'll melt into a you know a
steamy pile it'll be like that scene
from uh raiders of the lost ark
and they open up pandora's box and their
faces are just like
that's pretty much what i would imagine
here we go
mothers are persons but it seems to be
more inclusive like you're trying to
include another gender in that i'm all
about inclusion congresswoman there you
go
like inclusion equality equity you know
those things you know human beings like
she tried to make a point and he was
like do you know something i don't know
are are women not persons
i like to include everyone and she's
like okay okay moving on uh like you're
you attempted to make a point that was
very poorly done
and then you just conceded
it's you know like you're just like okay
thank you like that you ate you answered
exactly what i wanted you to do and it's
like you realize
you didn't make a point there right like
if anything that the point that you were
thinking you were making you weren't
actually making
you know what's funny about this clip is
that lauren beaubert
thinks she's smarter
than secretary bakara yeah
who's that uh
uh eric schmidt
eric schmidt yeah or ethan ethan ethan
schmidt
sorry eric schmidt from google very
smart guy ethan schmidt
anti-masters club not so smart
anti-masters club that's the video
that's the video that i wanted that i
wanted to play but let's let's go let's
go to
um let's let's we'll get to him maybe
uh in the alpha cook section let's go to
dishonorable mention for don't let me
forget about that yeah the he-man's
women is it he-man's woman haters club
is that the club he started yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay good good good um matt
gatz the uh petal con from from florida
um he why is he the bone or the
dishonorable mention for bonehead of the
week what what got him in this category
uh i'll pull up the clip for you but
matt gates uh decided to throw his hat
into the ring regarding this like
uh back and forth tiff joke late night
joke that was from um jimmy kimmel right
and it was all it all started with when
he's talking to marjorie taylor green is
that the great yeah yeah
yeah so basically to set it up uh marger
taylor green sends out a tweet that says
uh romney murkowski and collins all
three of them are voting for uh kbj
they're all pro pedophiles and that's
why she's on the bone head of the week
right that's like the main reason yeah
she got herself on there for that tweet
and some other stuff but mainly that
tweet and then
um
uh jimmy kimmel brings the tweet up on
his late night monologue and he says
where's will smith when you need him
right obviously alluding to the slap
right he didn't say
like oh you know he should do this but
he's like where's this guy when you need
him right by the way by the way
hilarious joke yeah i think i'm just
saying it yeah yeah no regardless of
what you think of the will smith chris
rock that's a great joke anyways go
ahead
so well i got this helicopter plane
thing going on oh dear yeah okay okay
all right i think it's good i think it's
gone i think it's good yeah i got to
work with the elements here okay so then
what ends up happening is marjory taylor
green says uh attention capital police
uh i'd like to report this
as uh
as a threat against my life right which
is hilarious considering the fact that
marjorie taylor green has no respect for
the capitol police who kept her and
other people at the capitol safe on
january 6th the people that she shits
all over him and eric swalwell i think
speaking of eric swallow he pointed out
that she voted against funding the
capital police exactly she didn't want
to give them the medal of honor she
didn't want to give them that she wanted
to give it to the j6 patriots she wanted
to give it to kyle ridden house she did
not want to give it to
uh the capitol police she didn't even
want to acknowledge
their role in saving their lives from
getting just [ __ ] right beaten down
right right
so she says that uh then uh jimmy kimmel
goes uh attention police i'd like to
report a joke right he goes back and
then she comes back and says like oh
this is an attack i get all these
different things like i i'm the victim
blah blah blah of course she is right
and then that's where we get onto this
the fire brand matt gates podcast you
know now wait a second so you're telling
me
i just want to be clear here
that marjorie taylor green this all
starts with a tweet where she accuses
someone of being a pedophile and then
she ends up
on a podcast bitching about this with a
pedophile is that what you're saying yep
an accused sex trafficker a child sex
trafficker a pro putin petticon oh this
is fantastic let's watch this clip here
i think this is the one isn't it this is
the one that you want me to play yeah
and by the way jimmy kimmel not only
would marjorie taylor green's husband
make quick work of you
oh so so wait a second so
matt gatz's
natural instinct to say that jimmy
kimmel was uh was um
threatening marjorie today they're gonna
used to threaten him yeah this is
beautiful this is right
marjorie taylor green would make quick
work of you and if you don't believe
that you can go ask the marines that did
pull-ups with her at the iowa state fair
and uh my guess is that jimmy jimmy
kimmel would not last too long if uh if
he himself were interested in engaging
in unprovoked terrible violence uh
against uh against this congresswoman
you mean you mean like uh uh unprovoked
violence like i don't know breaking into
a building and trying to commit a cheeto
dust kangaroo beating beating the
capitol police the police officers that
you called with a [ __ ] american and
confederate flag
is that the kind of is that the kind of
unprovoked violence that you're talking
about or even i mean
yeah let's talk about uh margaret taylor
green is is
ins like she has a real knack for being
vile and harassing people like look at
uh david hogg right uh a school a mass
shooting at a school survivor he's now
an activist does great work you know
leading the charge in terms of reform
uh
there are videos of her harassing him on
the street other school victims she's
harassing them
by asking them questions and and
bringing up the fact of like oh it's a
hoax are you guys oh yeah they're
kittens crisis actors
they continue to diddle kids over and
over and over again rather it's to shame
them because they were [ __ ] victims
of a school shooting and they were there
and they were traumatized and they're
trying to do something about it they
diddle kids that way they want to diddle
kids by marrying them in tennessee and
other states they want to dittle kids by
by sexualizing their gender it's all
over the place here is this [ __ ] this
this vile piece of [ __ ] um thinking uh
think she starts out she tweets
that uh romney murkowski and collins are
pro-pedophile because they're voting to
confirm kbj justice kbj now
and then she's thanking up
accused pedophile of defending her
oh this is here we go yeah and they go
and do it yeah and jimmy jimmy knows it
happens and you know and and so matt i'm
really grateful for you um as as wait
wait wait let's let's roll that back
because matt gatz is an accused sex trap
child sex trafficker
he is a pro-putin pedicon
a republican kid diddler let's listen to
this again let's make sure we get this
on the record matt i'm really grateful
for you um as as in your character and
because we need to recognize that women
are
the weaker sex
wait wait wait wait wait wait
i had no idea that those guys i had no
idea that was coming i did not see this
that was the other reason i put her on
the or that i was thinking of her list
not only was it this whole like back and
forth what was the fact that she put she
doubled down in the whole like women
come from adam's rib god created us we
are weaker we are the weaker sex
meanwhile she's also the one who had two
affairs that we know of with a
polyamorous tantric sex guru and the
manager at the crossfit gym that she was
a part of so marjorie taylor green to
come in here i just want to go on a
small little rain right here
go ahead yeah marcia taylor green to
come in again you know and try to talk
about you know the sanctity of marriage
and the role of a woman and the fact
that women are weaker you know she's
also the same woman that had two
separate affairs
open open affairs like people knew that
she was openly cheating on her husband
right and she was with a polyamorous
tantric sex scuba which is a mouthful
and also
the manager at the crossfit gym that she
was a part of so margery taylor green to
come in here all righteous and and
christian like and women are are you
know are are the the the result of
adam's rib from god who created us we
are weaker men are the superior race or
or or gender in this scenario
and so as a woman we have to serve them
much like i'm sure josh hawley really
wants you know barefoot in the kitchen
cookie making taking care of the kids
right margie taylor green's like you
know and they want their 12 year old
girls to serve to to be
to be uh servants to them as well as
child brides but here's the thing i
haven't seen i haven't seen anyone bring
up and you know i don't know if this is
the right take but i will say this
marjorie taylor green is claiming that
women are the weaker sex if women are
the weaker sex then why would she want
to be in congress right why wouldn't she
support a man right again i don't
believe that i don't know but using her
logic if women are the weaker sex then
why would she go against a man
who she did run against in the
congressional race for her district why
would she not want a man
to be in a role like that if women are
weaker then that would make me feel like
women aren't the appropriate people to
be in congress according to her logic
right well
here's i think here's what she's trying
she's trying to force feed
when someone says what's a woman the
weaker sex right that's the like that's
the and
and this is why they get confused
because she says the weaker sex right
she says that on purpose not the weaker
gender right the weaker sex because
these boneheads out there that's why
they're sexualizing kids gender because
gender the word gender and the word sex
in the dictionary they sort of share a
definition right they sort of share a
definition so they think because they
share a definition gender has to do with
sex sex has to do with gender so that's
why she's saying this stuff that's
that's the language that they're using
that's right
and and here's the thing like
women
you know
the fact that she would say women are
the weaker sex right okay let's let's
also keep in mind that women you know if
they're bearing children that's nine
around nine months maybe a little longer
depending if you're you know like uh
overdue but that's nine months of
carrying another thing in your body
right where you have to like you got
[ __ ] pain your arch is hurt your back
hurts you're irritable uh you you've got
uh you know stress emotional physical
problems going on
a woman has to deal with that for nine
or so months right
then you're like hey once i had this kid
now i have to raise this kid right i
gotta i gotta breastfeed i gotta be up
at all hours i got to make sure that my
finances are in order i got to make sure
that i have the support emotionally and
from my friends and family to help me
you know financially as well through
this situation then you know they grow
up a lot of stress right teenagers
whatever we've all been there like
that's not an easy job and that is not
an easy job for someone who's weak not
only that but you've got a woman who is
you know if she's a single parent she's
got to you know work even harder right a
woman has to work just as hard well not
justice or has to work harder
to to validate herself in just the world
right that's not even including the fact
that if you're a woman who is a person
of color right like we just saw this
through the whole skoda syrians right
we've got sexist misogynistic racist
things that happen through there so to
call women weaker
is is [ __ ] in my in my opinion
the fact that marjorie taylor greene
would just say women are weaker
i says is [ __ ] [ __ ] right women
are i would say are much stronger than a
lot of men and we've talked about this
before where women you know have to come
in and [ __ ] pick up the [ __ ] right
right they got despite the fact they
don't want to right they don't want to
do that they don't have to come in and
do extra work right like whether you're
in a relationship uh it's your parents
your mother you know whatever whatever
yeah right like women come in and have
to clean that up right they're the ones
who have to clean up because men thought
they could do it themselves you know
whether they're super inflated egos or
what have you they come in they [ __ ] it
up and then
women come in and they have to they have
to they have to fix it they have to
clean it up despite again despite the
fact that they don't want to they want
to just [ __ ] live their lives and do
what they want to do with equal footing
as men but they have to do their job and
they need to come and help support and
do a man's job right and then the man
goes i did that and i take all the
credit that's right so you've got a
woman doing you know a job and a half
two jobs and then marger taylor green
over here with her own privilege to say
women are the weaker sex and if that's
true then you shouldn't be in congress
you should not be running and
representing the people because
obviously that's a harder job and you
know resign that resides because a man
should be the one who's doing that well
you know what i don't know sex
you know i i think i think you're right
on the pregnancy thing that uh um
they're really a woman is probably
that's the only reason why we exist as a
human race is because the women actually
carry uh that carry the babies because a
guy like matt gatz if he had to um oh
god i if he had to carry a baby that guy
wouldn't last [ __ ] 30 goddamn days
[Music]
no shut the [ __ ] up like matt gates
is a piece of [ __ ] and is just
and anyway i mean i i i i couldn't i
couldn't yeah yeah okay i do want to
call out okay mj has been telling us to
play the stephen colbert club which we
are going to play
yeah so stephen colbert is on uh on a
set for his late night show right uh
with stephen colbert i i want to note
here mj's comment she put a star see how
she put the star in front of it um i i
told everyone earlier to put a star if
they want to
it's kind of like the signal so everyone
in the chat knows it's like a little
like a little hey hey pay attention to
me yeah a little podcast right so if
you're talking to us yeah and put a star
in front of if you're yeah that's a good
thing that's a good idea look at that
innovation that's what we do here we
innovate so what's up
so the setup here is uh stephen colbert
this is a pre-show moment right like
i've been i actually this isn't part of
the show this no this is not part of the
show like i i've uh when i was in new
york years ago when letterman was still
um
uh when he was still
on the air i went to one of his tapings
um and there's a lot of fun right you've
got you know he comes out you know tell
some jokes uh gets to know the audience
and answer some questions right and it's
just kind of like a pre-show kind of
hype and this is that moment where
stephen colbert they're not filming uh
from what i understand this is before it
could have been also during a commercial
break but i doubt it if there was a
guest so i'm gonna say this is before
this is before the show before the show
starts he comes out and like warms up
warms up right right yeah gets him
laughing no he lets people ask questions
and they ask a question and this college
student asks a question uh and i don't
want to i don't want to talk anymore
about it because the question then sets
it up oh okay okay for uh by the way mj
thank you again for the super sticker
she said that's for the for gabe's rant
oh thank you yeah so thank you so much
and see if anyone wants to get on the
super chat you can there thank you mj
for not only um
calling out this clip but for the super
sticker let's play the clip and let's
see let's see what the question is i
think it's really light so if we can't
hear it i'll try to say it so yeah you
guys can hear it
hey steven i'm a college student
my question is if you're if you had
donald trump on your show tonight what
would you ask him
crowd goes
well we're not broadcasting right now so
i'd say what does vladimir putin's taste
like
now if you didn't hear if you didn't
hear keith stephen colbert may or may
not have said
um
because he's not on the air he's right
they're clearly not recording for the
show for for airing on tv they are
recording because we are watching the
video but he said what he would ask
donald trump what does vladimir putin's
dick taste like
you know which is um yeah
so let's watch the rest of the clip
he's a little ditty
[Music]
[Applause]
he's dancing around
[Music]
and don't don't say that joke in front
of vladimir putin's wife because
i don't know i've only seen vlad on
horseback
i thought that was i thought that was
his wife
maybe honestly
and the fishing that was his wife i have
no idea i have no idea um you know
talking to vladimir putin about alpha
cucks like vladimir putin because
vladimir putin is an alpha cuck you know
he thinks he's he's got to be manly and
he i am alpha which if you have to say
you're out you're not alpha yeah you
know that um but we have a we have a
special alpha cuck this week can you can
you tell us who
representative tom leatherwood is and
why he got alpha cuck of the week yeah
yeah so i just want to point out also to
anyone who's listening and watching when
i find these photos of people i do a
very i go i dig around to find the the
best and by best i mean the worst photo
right like we got to really represent
who these people are on the show
and tom leatherwood really came out of
nowhere uh because i i can only find
like three photos of him online right
he's uh a local he's a he's a
representative from tennessee but he
entered in with a with another woman um
this bill that was the uh
what did we call it there's the mary
kidd bill that midas touch calls it it's
the pedophile bill it's the pedophile
the pedocon
republican kid diddler bill right
exactly they wanted little kids right
grand old pedophiles is what the gop is
now right so or or yeah you know go
ahead so so tom leatherwood over here
says hey you know what
we should make marrying people easier
and then everyone's like okay and he's
like and by easier i mean we shouldn't
have an age limit at all right people
should just be able to marry whoever
they want right because here's here's
kind of the thing that they're trying to
do right because the [ __ ] thing
about because they're trying to make it
to where it's like oh well it's because
we hate gay people is why we're doing
this bill it's kind of where they're
coming from right like yeah they're like
well we have to have some sort of thing
that makes it look like we're hating
someone we're republicans so we
definitely have to discriminate and hate
on someone so that's like the direction
of the bill right right so so what their
what their idea is and this is gonna
happen in all states folks they're going
states are gonna try to out tennessee
tennessee i'm sure florida will do what
texas do and then everyone will try to
out florida florida out texas texas
right missouri apparently already has
one on the slate that's gonna go through
since
the decision by the supreme court that
makes
marriage between uh two people of the
same gender if they want to get married
a state has to issue a marriage license
right
and because these uh pedo cons these
republican kid diddlers believe which is
all [ __ ] that marriage is sacred and
it's a sanctity of marriage and blah
blah blah they want to come up with an
alternative marriage which immediately
immediately you're like what the [ __ ]
attended a marriage
because what they want to do is they
want to pretend like they're boxing out
lgbtq people from this alternative
marriage because there's the old
marriage which is now
now gay marriage and then there's this
new marriage which they
call like a common law type marriage
right but what they're doing what
they're doing is using this law by
making it look like it's anti-lgbtq
which their base is going to be
oh they're going to be happy about this
because it hates and discriminates
against people and that's what they love
they love that kind of [ __ ]
but what it does is it makes it to where
an old man can marry a little child a
little girl
but let's listen here because here is um
because the other well the other thing
too
on this build is the fact that
they say
uh people who are trans or gay or
whatever are groomers right right just
just another just so just another
projection by the gop inside the
pedophile bill right calling someone
else right right except
these people are groomers and we need to
protect them and the only way to protect
them is to marry them
and by doing so we need to groom these
children right like it's [ __ ] gross
it's [ __ ] twisted in the logic
and they're not going to stop folks this
pedocon stuff they're not going to stop
this so
because we started a yelling scream and
i'm going to take credit for it because
we did a lot of yelling and screaming on
the show and i did a lot of tweeting i
put out a lot of video and and i think
it
pushed people to to say more outlandish
stuff about this bill because i think
that's one thing democrats are horrible
at they are so scared of saying the
outright truth and we [ __ ] don't do
not shy away from saying what is
actually happening and these are a bunch
of goddamn pedophiles trying to pass
state laws to make sure they can marry
little girls that is what they're trying
to do no matter how they try to dress it
up no matter how they try to spin it
but
here we go is a video
of
representatives in the state of
tennessee trying to push back on this um
let's listen in here is there no age
limit in this bill my understanding
now this this is tom leatherwood this is
the guy who's the apple cook now he's
he's kind of the big proponent behind
the the bill is that right yep yeah yeah
him there's another woman as well but uh
he's the main he's the main face of uh
of this bill and it just happens that he
he's the main face of the bill and
if you look at tom leatherwood you would
um
you would really suspect i don't know
but right so when i when i said earlier
i was like oh i really try to do a good
job of finding you know really bad
photos of people i looked at his photo
and obviously there's only a few around
the internet because he's just not known
until this moment
but his photo in and of itself
looks like he
might be might be a petticon yeah well i
think he is a pentagon let's listen
standing you know 18 is the way this
would be construed i just want to make
sure there wasn't an explicit agent in
my concern okay i'm sorry i didn't
understand he's like 18 is what we
because let's let's let's back up a bit
because in tennessee the current
marriage law is that a 17 year old can
give consent
that is the current law um and this this
that wasn't young enough man wasn't
young enough well and and the way that
they're trying to get around this age
limit is not change that law what
they're trying to do is make a new way
of getting married
listen to this is what they're doing a
new way
of getting married because the sanctity
of the other marriage is lost and now
their religion forces them to have this
new way of getting married because
frankly they can't marry a 12 year old
girl with the old way of getting married
so now they got to invent a new way of
getting married right so let's listen in
tennessee and i don't think we want to
get away from that you're aware that our
current law does have an age limit yes
we're going to pass this bill out with
no age limit on here i would hope that
we would consider that and vote against
this bill we're making a whole bunch to
do in getting off on in the weeds here
h7
this is this is another republican
saying we're getting off in the weeds
listen guys you guys are focusing on the
wrong details right okay the age thing
not a big deal no one's gonna try to
just uh i don't know take advantage of
this bill and marry someone younger and
then say well you guys pass it it's a
bill because here's the thing these guys
you would not bring it up if you
yourself did not have a desire to take
advantage
of that new passing of a bill right if
you
really if
like them being like oh you know what uh
if we really did feel this way then we
would put an age restriction on it
especially if we want to make it our own
common law and we want to box out lgbtq
or gay or whoever
uh
if age isn't a problem then you wouldn't
even touch it right or you would
redefine it for this common-law marriage
but the fact that you're saying there's
no age restriction honestly you can
marry as young as you want right like
the idea that they would even allow that
and then being like oh well you know i
didn't really think about it until now
[ __ ] that you thought about it when you
wrote it right when you redlined the age
out you yourself said yeah now
seventeen's not young enough gotta go
younger gotta get him when you're
writing the bill and you're like okay
we're gonna make a new kind of marriage
right we're gonna make a new kind of
marriage because our religion wants a
new kind of marriage right
how i you know marriage should be
between a man and a woman and let's
what's the age limit that we should have
on the you know well most places would
accept you know and uh look at look at
adults it's 18 they're like nope we're
not doing 18. well we currently have 17.
nope we're not doing 17. it's like what
do you want he's like no age yeah no age
limit i you can't abort babies but you
sure as hell can marry them yeah let's
listen into what this this republican
bonehead continues to say
still applicable no sir that applies to
marriage licenses this creates a
different part this does not come from a
place of kindness and understanding but
rather a place of prejudice and contempt
the rhetoric behind this bill implies
that gay men and women have devalued or
tainted the marriage process in
tennessee a separate registry religion
as a guise to avoid using the same
licenses afforded to same-sex couples
the nicest word that comes to mind is
silly make no mistake about it same sex
marriages the nicest feelings yeah
that's the nicest like that's like the
filth that is like filtered filtered
filtered right you respond to be like
this is silly it's like no it's goddamn
right it's disgusting
but the other thing too is like these
these republicans like from the you know
the grand old pedophiles what they like
when you get married you have to pay for
a marriage license right you have to you
know
do the whole thing and get the pay in
and do it right yeah well you got it you
got to write it and write it down right
right but you know as a married couple
now you're paying taxes and doing this
and you got different benefits and stuff
like you yourself as a married couple
are paying more into the system of that
state right or of that community so
the fact that they'd be like you know
what
we don't want as much money we don't
want as much this we don't want it like
by denying these people that they're
like you know what we will do we're a
rich old white man and i'm [ __ ]
real stingy with my money and i want to
get around it by doing a common law
marriage because i don't have to pay for
a marriage license i don't have to do
this i have to do that i just got to
groom that kid and it's cheap and it's
free you know that's the way that they
think about it that's the other thing
about this
is because this is called a common law
marriage right yeah yeah and if anyone
is familiar with states that have common
law marriage which a lot of states do
have a common law marriage and generally
what it means is if two people are
together for a very long period of time
and by together i mean they actually
have a relationship like a financial
relationship they own a house together
they own cars together they own bank
accounts together they own retirement
accounts together a lot of times the
state will will recognize them as a
common law marriage meaning
you're you're actually married you don't
know it we don't know it but you you are
married right
these [ __ ] gross old ass white men
want to have a common-law marriage now
think about that that means that the
state doesn't know that they're married
to these children
they
have ownership yeah yeah with these
children right these children are common
law marriage with them right
that is the thing that they're trying to
do is trying to skirt that people would
even know that they're married to
children right
that's and it's the definition
of groomer and really honestly
up until
the last really the last year when
they've really tried to sexualize uh
children's gender they've really went
after uh trans gender children they went
after lgbtq children and children that
have lgbtq parents
because they're going after those
parents as well
those children who ha who aren't who
aren't
in the lgbt community themselves but
their parents are right they're going
after those children as well
it really i never heard the word groomer
much i never did i didn't understand
that because i i just i didn't know that
and a lot of people
have even in my dm's have said this word
has been attached to the lgbt community
for a long time and let's finish let's
finish to see what dakota says here
because i think it's relevant is there
no basis for obstructing the equal
dignity we as lgbt people expect as
citizens of the greatest country in the
world may god continue to bless
tennessee frankly i feel kind of like
the tide has changed and if there's any
hostility it's against those people do
believe marriage comes from god and do
believe it's between one man and woman
they don't deserve the hostility they're
getting and if there's any lack of
kindness or understanding it's not on
the part of the people bringing this
jesus christ thank you what hostility i
have no idea is coming towards a
normative marriage that is
man and woman who is who is attacking
these people again
lgbtq
who you know same sex but like whoever
you are wherever you fall and whoever
your partner is and wherever they fall
they don't give a flying [ __ ] what
another person who is a man and a woman
who has a just a normal marriage
has to they don't care they don't want
to go into your house they don't want to
tell you what to do they don't want to
tell you how to live your life they
don't know how to tell you how to how to
handle your relationship they're like
listen i'm in my own home this is my
[ __ ] domain i do my own [ __ ] i'm
happy with my partner i don't want to
have to deal with your [ __ ] and
you're [ __ ] up christianity in the way
that you perceive marriage to be because
it's not one way it's a spectrum in
terms of how we all accept each other
and how we marry each other so the fact
that these people again the gop the
grand old pedophiles the grand old
projectionist is what they are right no
[ __ ] they come in here and they assume
that other people again we're the victim
we're the victim people are attacking us
no they're not no one [ __ ] cares
about you dude it's a fact that you have
now faded in to just irrelevant
just like in the to the sidelines that
they're like oh well we're not getting
the attention anymore people look at us
look at us we're the victim because
these other people these people who are
different than us these people who don't
accept the the normal man-woman
relationship
uh want to have something different
they're they're attacking the sanctity
of the marriage that was that was
developed in the bible right which again
the bible [ __ ] bunch of stories by a
by a bunch of random people making
[ __ ] up and about jesus who was a
goddamn grifter like let's just call
what it is right he was a homeless
magician on the street that was trying
to turn water into wine and doing these
tricks and you know dude they were
[ __ ] they're all [ __ ] each other
okay
okay let's just call what is in the
bible everyone was [ __ ] everyone okay
and that's that's the that's the that's
the king gay bible right there i'm
telling you how it really was everyone
in the bible was [ __ ] each other okay
they were [ __ ] going at it 24 7 and
what they wrote about was how people
they how they think people should be
so when i see
uh wait wait are you saying are you
saying the uh the disciples were
republican is that what you're saying
i'm saying i'm saying here's the thing i
also think that
the i think that the the the disciples
the 12 of them you know plus you know
judas who
then there was like 11 obviously but i
look at the 12 and i say nah dude
they're all [ __ ] right now the books
that they wrote i think they actually
wrote all the savage [ __ ] that they did
and then when eventually when the church
found these like manuals they're like
whoa [ __ ]
you know what we need to do you know we
do the opposite this [ __ ] up right what
they did is they redlined every
[ __ ] thing in those in those
the book of the book of you know of luke
and everything they were just like nope
no this this [ __ ] was raunchy as [ __ ] we
need to get this out of here and they
then said you know what this is what
they actually said you know because it
was in another language it was in hebrew
or whatever you know
we need to translate it into english and
uh the way that it actually translates
because here's the thing i would say
there's actual some truth to this
because it's the way that they
they changed uh um homosexual right in
the bible uh i think it was pedophile or
something wrong that was translated and
they translated it to homosexual
and it's that type of just like liberal
translation they made in there makes me
think that when it was jesus was around
before and after [ __ ] was crazy
it was wild and what they wrote about
and what they transcribed it to be was
not actually what it was it might have
been some prude over here in his house
and his dwelling with
what he thought his wife or some [ __ ]
incel right they're like it should be
like this
and so when you see these people like
leatherwood
they're just projecting what they
what they feel like everyone should be
right and again it's it comes from a
place internally which is an insecurity
or or lack of confidence or or the fact
that they just can't be who they truly
are then they
have to then map this on to other people
and this example of him trying to pass
this bill where he goes you know what
we should let anyone marry anyone of any
age and everyone's like yo yo yo uh we
already have an age right right right
like why we need to redefine this he
goes well i never thought it would
anyone would take advantage of this and
i never thought that that someone would
would say oh well i could marry a kid i
mean meanwhile
really thinking he's like after this is
done i'm gonna get myself a second and
third wife and the other part of this
too is the fact that
um
you look at when you're like filing
taxes right you're like oh i have a
dependent i have to i have to claim a
dependent i don't even know how that
[ __ ] works like you have the parents
who go yep you're now under this
household and this random old white dude
says this girl is now mine and i have to
like i don't know exactly how that works
i'm not an accountant and i'm not a
[ __ ] pedophile but these people are
trying to slip through the cracks and
take advantage of loopholes so that they
can just live their lives their best
lives right a bunch of these rando pedo
cons right
it's insane and so when i see this [ __ ]
i'm just like you guys are [ __ ]
disgusted and gross and vile and i'm
glad that other people on the on on this
committee that were listening were like
yo
are we really this is this is [ __ ] up
right and the guy and this is just
tuesday are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me this
is insane tuesday this is nuts and then
you've got the guy who again he's like
in the nicest way possible again his
[ __ ] filter filter filter filter
filter filtered oh
it's silly it's silly it's ridiculous so
so uh thank you um tom leatherwood for i
guess thank you for uh joining the awful
cooks his face does look like leather
like it's just like whoosh that's the
other thing too is this creep's name is
leatherwood oh yeah you can't make it it
sounds like a villain's name right like
a like a like a like a white guy who
you're like who in this town killed
someone right leatherwood
and you're like leatherwood and he
didn't even kill one person he's got 30
bodies in the basement right you know
like that's the type of and he tried to
marry every single one of them it's
really even they said no and he was like
you'll be my forever bride right that's
common law gives me the ability to marry
tom leatherwood if he doesn't get his
way he will make forever brides i
guarantee it that's the type of guy that
he is oh my god well there uh our winner
of the week uh marjorie taylor green
there are several reasons we already
discussed one reason why but i i want to
play
a video but before that let's give her
her due here for her win
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
marjorie taylor green wins again
bonehead of the week i do want to play
because we know
she thinks um
people are pro-pedophile she's
projecting uh her her the petticon
republican kid diddler ways but there is
one other thing that she was projecting
here and she tried to do this thing
where she uh went uh
after jamie raskin on the floor of the
house and he was having none of it let's
listen to what his response was to
marjorie taylor again let's listen
the general lady i think said something
about the russian hoax or
russian collusion i accept the heckling
mr speaker that that's all right
because if she wants to continue to
stand with vladimir putin and his brutal
bloody invasion against the people of
ukraine she is free to do so and we
understand there is a strong
trump putin axis in the general ladies
party she wants to continue to stand
with vladimir putin donald trump that is
her prerogative but please do it on your
own time fourth win
he forth with her what the he fourth
with no one says that no one says no
no
listen
when you can out saki
uh jinsaki you are [ __ ] you are in
the hall of fame of slam dunks and
dunking these pro putin petticons into
the [ __ ] trash that was absolutely
and he's done this like i don't know
four or five times this last week yeah
he's absolutely bald these little these
petticons up into like little dry
boogers and flicked them all the way
across the room it is crazy it is crazy
that they would even attempt
attempt to go after jamie raskin and we
need more of this absolutely more of
this more yes and i think he i think he
personally takes like any anything that
margie taylor green has to say i think
he personally takes offense to it
because his role in the capitals uh in
the january 6 capital uh you know uh uh
impeachment hearings right towards
donald trump he was up there he made a
great case and then you got people
obviously like margaret taylor green
here like me it was not a real thing it
was not an insurrection and he's like
[ __ ] you man i looked at hours of
footage and i have [ __ ] i was there
he was there he was [ __ ] there it's
it's incredible um so thank you marjorie
taylor green for coming in um at the
very beginning and all the way through
the poll winning bonehead of the week
join us every single week on friday in
the second hour the the tony michaels
podcast bonehead of the week and go
download it on apple spotify and google
and also follow us on the minus touch
facebook page youtube twitter twitch
that is bone end of the week thank you
very much we'll be right back after the
song
[Music]
[Applause]